foreign
and welcome to Simply learns YouTube
channel in today's video we are diving
deep into the world of computer security
specifically we'll discuss Trojans what
they are how to detect them and most
importantly how to effectively remove
them from your system by the end of this
video you'll have the knowledge you need
to keep your computer safe and secure
but before we begin if you enjoy
watching these videos and find them
interesting then subscribe to our
Channel because we bring the best videos
for you daily also hit the Bell icon to
never miss any updates from Simply learn
if you want to master the field of cyber
security then simply learns postgraduate
program in cyber security in
collaboration with MIT is clearly the
right choice for you this postgraduate
program in cyber security is designed to
equip you with the skills required to
become an expert in the rapidly growing
field of cyber security
the cyber security program aims to help
you stay ahead of all the latest cyber
security Trends key features of this
program includes simply learned
postgraduate certificate master classes
from MIT faculty featuring modules from
mitscc and EC Council access to ceh Kit
25 plus Hands-On projects and many more
the cyber security certification program
begins with introductory level skills
and then progresses to advance cyber
security Technologies
this program covers all the essential
skills you will need to become an expert
in the field of cyber security
cyber security is indeed one of the top
concerns of businesses today in an
industry from securing data to
anticipating cyber attacks and placing
enterprise-wide safeguards to prevent
them employers worldwide are
increasingly looking for qualified cyber
Security Professionals to join them so
what are you waiting for find the course
link mentioned in the description box
below and enroll now before we dive into
the removal process let's have a solid
understanding of what Trojans are
a Trojan short form for Trojan horse is
a type of malicious software that
disguises itself as a legitimate
software once inside your system it can
perform various malicious actions from
stealing sensitive informations to
giving hackers unauthorized access to
computers
Trojans masquerade as legitimate
software or files tricking users into
installing them they often come bundled
with seemingly harmless software or are
hidden with enticing email attachment
detecting Trojans is crucial to
safeguarding your system some common
signs that your computer might be
infected are unusual system Behavior
sudden slowdowns crashes or freezes can
indicate atrogen's presence
you notice that your computer is
suddenly behaving erratically such as
becoming unusually slow or crashing
frequently it could be a sign that a
Trojan has infiltrated your system
these behaviors are often a result of
the Trojans interference with your
system's normal functioning unexpected
pop-ups end its if you notice an
increase in intrusive pop-ups or ads it
could be a sign of a Trojan Trojans
often display unwanted pop-up ads on
your screen even where you are not
browsing the internet these ads can be
highly invisible and disruptive and they
are a common sign that your system might
be compromised
unauthorized access if you find
unfamiliar accounts or activities on
your system it's time to investigate if
you notice that there are unauthorized
accounts on your computer or UC files
and folders that you didn't create it
clearly indicates that a Trojan might
have granted hackers access to your
system this could lead to Data Theft or
even remote control of your computer
changes in files and settings Trojan can
alter your files and settings and even
your browser's homepage Trojans often
manipulate files settings and
configurations on your computer you
might notice that your desktop icons
have been rearranged your browser's home
page has been changed without your
permission our files have been deleted
or modified
unexplained network activity an
unusually high amount of data usage or
network activity might point to a Trojan
infection
If You observe a significant increase in
your network activity or data usage and
you haven't knowingly downloaded or
uploaded large files it's a sign that a
Trojan might be using your network
connection for malicious purposes
removing Trojans let's roll up our
sleeves to start the removal process
remember it's essential to follow each
step carefully the first step is
disconnect from the network first thing
first disconnect from the internet to
prevent the Trojan from communicating
with its suits Trojans often establish
connections with their command and
control servers over the internet
by disconnecting from the internet you
cut off the Trojan's ability to
communicate and receive further
instructions making the removal process
more effective the second step is boot
into safe mode reboot your computer and
enter safe mode this limits the Trojan's
ability to run and make removing it
easier safe mode is a special mode in
which your computer starts with minimal
essential drivers and processes this
helps prevent Trojans from loading their
malicious components making it safer to
perform removal procedures without
interference the third step is
identifying the Trojan use your system's
task manager to identify suspicious
processes make a note of any unfamiliar
names access your computer's task
manager and look for processes that use
a significant amount of system resources
or have suspicious names keep an eye out
for processes that you don't recognize
or that seem unrelated to your usual
programs
the next step is backup your data before
proceeding backup your important files
you want to ensure you don't lose
anything valuable during the removal
process
backing up your data is crucial because
the removal process might involves
making changes to your system that could
potentially result in data loss
by creating a backup you have a safety
net in case something goes wrong during
the removal
the fifth step is manual removal this
step is suggested for advanced use only
if you are comfortable you can try
manual removal but this is best suited
for tech savvy use manual removal
involves directly interacting with
system files settings and the Windows
registry this can be risky if not done
correctly as you could inadvertently
cause further damage to your system it's
recommended primarily for experienced
users who are familiar with system
mechanics
the first is delete suspicious file
search for files that you suspect might
be related to the Trojan these files
might be located in your system folders
or temporary directories be cautious not
to delete files that are essential for
your operating systems functionality
edit the registry to remove Trojan
related entries accessing the Windows
registry allows you to remove any
entries that the Trojan has added
however modifying the registry can have
serious consequences if done incorrectly
so extreme question is advised
the third is remove startup entries
associated with Trojan Trojans often add
entries to your system startup programs
to ensure they run every time your
computer boots up identifying and
disabling these entries can prevent
Trojan from launching the last step is
scan with reputable anti-malware
software for most users using trusted
anti-malware software is the safer
choice
the first step is download and install
choose a reliable anti-malware program
and install it select an anti-malware
program with a good reputation and
positive reviews make sure it's from a
reputable source and offers real-time
protection as this can help prevent
future infections update the database
update the software's database to ensure
it recognizes the latest threats and
anti-malware programs Effectiveness
relies on its database of known malware
signatures regularly updating this
database ensures that the program can
detect and remove the latest threats
including new variations of Trojans
perform a system check initiate a
comprehensive scan of your system a full
system scan checks all files folders and
areas of your computer for any signs of
malware including Trojan this thorough
examination is crucial to ensure that no
traces of the Trojan Remain the last is
quarantine and remove if the software
detects a Trojan quarantine and then
remove it according to its instructions
quarantining a suspected Trojan isolates
it from the rest of your system
preventing it from causing further harm
after the quarantine you can review the
results and then remove the thread
completely so these are the steps you
should follow if your system gets
affected by any project
in conclusion Trojans are dangerous and
deceitful fiber threats that can cause
severe damage to your computer and
compromise your personal information
armed with knowledge and the proper
security measures you can protect
yourself from falling victim to these
malicious attacks remember always stay
vigilant and take precautions when using
the internet to ensure Online safety on
that note do you guys know that many
individuals have attained high salaries
and better career opportunities through
a post-graduate program so before we end
this video let's take a minute to hear
it out from our users who have
experienced massive success in their
career hi I'm Philip I'm 61 years old
and last year iopskill with simply
learned postgraduate program in cyber
security after working 30 years in the
IIT sector in various different profiles
I'm happy to tell you that I was able to
clear and pass my cissp and ccsp
certification exams on the first attempt
after taking the course of course I must
say was packed with practical examples
but highly skilled certified instructors
I worked with many companies before the
security analysts and the architect on a
contract basis but I needed some
stability which I got with the job I
just started with Infosys as a cyber
security consultant
happened after I took the course first
and foremost I've been a learner be a
learner first
and with that we have come to the end of
this video on how to remove Trojans we
hope you found this video informative
and helpful if you have any doubts or
questions regarding this topic then
please feel free to drop them down in
the comment section below and if you are
interested in learning more about
different Technologies then there are
plenty of resources available at simply
loan you can also check out our website
for more information on different
certifications thank you for watching
and we'll see you next time till then
stay safe and keep learning with simply
learn
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here